the jurogan experience i don't know what
to think about that i've been saying
this that was halloween yeah that was
little wayne and little wayne was going
crazy spending all his money and putting
diamonds in his forehead with that was
that little vert who's that guy that did
that with diamond
yeah what do you mean put diamonds in
his forehead dude had a giant diamond
inserted into his forehead and then
someone stole it wait oh wait
grabbed it ripped it out wait a minute
you don't know about this like the guy
from it says someone no he's got a new
one there's a new rapper that has a gold
chain surgically implanted into his head
he did it before
he beat somebody doing it and then
someone stole it like in
an adventure
like thanos they pulled the thing out of
his phone so this guy has these gold
chains
[Music]
is a kid wow really brushing his metal
teeth but this i want to know how he got
those inserted in his head the gold
chains they can do that plus that shape
that's a cool look
about going that way is there guys that
have snap
i'm bald i can't wear a 2k but i could
wear that i'm thinking about wearing oh
my god
just how about this not gold change but
just gold studs that's a really bad idea
though to just like beads gold that's a
very yankable
thing uh look he's got the neck thing
where his neck is going to grow are you
saying that's not removable he's going
to have a giraffe neck yeah he's going
to have a drought like this oils around
his neck as a child it's actually very
regal to have a long neck by the way
it's very royal like a 7 foot tall guy's
neck yeah yeah
uh
he had he underwent surgery in april
allowing him to hang dozens of chains
from his head
i had it as a hook that's implanted in
my head and that hook has hooks so
they're all hooked in my skull under my
skin
he said in a viral clip this is my hair
golden hair the first rapper to have
gold hair implanted in human history
the word hair in a hook is said so many
times
jamie please see if there's like
detailed images that depict the surgery
and the the subsequent uh bleeding trump
did it first dude
imagine that though this [ __ ] kids
are very innovative that's like
cyberpunk [ __ ] dude it's pretty wild i'm
impressed that's a waste of money no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
40 million dollars stupid [ __ ]
paintings how awesome if god looking
if you had gold chains implanted into
your head how [ __ ] cool would that
look
i might i don't i'm thinking of doing
something radical like that i'll get
that clown here yeah man why did you
stop here you and i kurt we're bald
let's get something funky i'm basically
bald
no you're doing way better i know he's
is this privileged piece of [ __ ] yeah
shut the [ __ ] up
i love actual ball people i'd love to
have that salad you know one thing for i
don't know what i searched for on
instagram right but you know how you
search something then the algorithm
shows you all these things now yeah
maybe i clicked on one that i saw in the
search just taking a [ __ ] one day bored
but there is a whole movement of guys
gluing wigs to their head
oh yes there is yeah yeah like wait what
do you mean gluing it like like ball
guys it's like all the ones that i get
are they take it off sometimes i don't
know but they show a guy like looking
like this like
and then the guy likes this
squirts the glue on the head and puts
this crazy wig and then the guy's like
ah
why doesn't he do that because this guy
does get excited about us this is his
move i'm gonna show you i'm gonna show
you i'm gonna send this to jamie because
i i don't know they i you know how you
get on an algorithm and then the
algorithm just sends oh i know
immediately i get i get to one it's
pretty great because like youtube does
that too where you just it's just
okay glue
i'll find you these shirts are superior
what is this i got one on the screen oh
there's one of them yeah there's there's
a ton of these guys oh my god that looks
like uh mexican me there's so many of
these guys they they
there's but this
for whatever reason i don't know what
country it is yeah they look sad
um [ __ ] sad
ain't got no hair
and then this guy comes along and glues
down this look at this hey watch this
bam look at my [ __ ] hair now
see wow but they'll show the process
like i'm so sad that's pretty amazing uh
my any man can have lesbian hair now
that is the times but the thing is
though you're gluing it look at that i
know how do you get that off
it doesn't look good it looks [ __ ]
good it looks [ __ ] amazing that looks
[ __ ] good
i feel like it would look good for a day
dude who's the guy from [ __ ] uh the
glue will get loose how heavy would you
communicate with changing joel
mchale joel mchale yeah i met him in
person
and his whatever cause you remember
where he came from right the burger king
commercials i do not remember the burger
king commercial yeah before all that he
was a guy who was going bald in burger
king commercials it was like uh copying
the success of the office and it would
be like i thought i told you a whopper
and uh he was losing and then he had an
amazing dragon ball z hair
he does have grey hair dude and i asked
him point blank because i would be like
what do you do to hold your hair i
immediately will ask somebody that
oh okay so this is back in the disney
so that's right when i was at that hair
loss i asked him what does he do to hold
his hair and he didn't tell me he
wouldn't tie it huh he probably had to
keep it tight because he's a good plug
no slip sink ships and you've got loose
lips pal
right now
if i could help people that
to have joel mchale i would feel it was
my duty to do that watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify